okay four people joining the live stream
we are working on database connectivity
for version 12 of open language and
actually I realized we're writing a page
about relational databases but basically
every function on here applies to entity
classes in general does it not except
for the stuff about SQL things so all of
this stuff down here really is part of
the general knowledge management stuff
is that not correct
anybody comment on that Thanks
all right so it's part of this
Tonie code would you like to comment on
this here yes
so those functions should work properly
with any beckoned so really we we should
have um you know those functions should
also be on this page maybe this a
different viewpoint like we have here
under relational database page the more
relational view of the things
so where would you put them on this page
around entity class because the
implicitly defined entity class were the
first
constructs with which we could do some
queries in the entity language
okay but then we've got all kinds of
things like entity properties here um
maybe we need some
I think that a nice way to divide things
up is basically things that didn't go in
the first argument identity class of
entity value-oriented least and thinks
that actually in the second things like
custom entity stores by the way don't
bleep wires an entity register on here
what these things here are these not
what were these future eyes i guess they
should not be futurist that was probably
the first time i ended at that guide
page
that didn't know about the future
ization
okay well arguably okay so those should
be unfused yes okay so now here how
would we characterize this
you
all the commas here correct
I don't know um
okay so really what there is
is something here that we want to add um
something about manipulating computing
with entity classes is that right
but I feel like this should go lower
down on the page I think it should go
here
I think Anthony value should come up
okay hence two classes implicitly
defined by property values and then
computing with entity classes is that a
reasonable characterization of what
we're talking about here it's more like
the process of constructing those entity
classes is different yeah things to do
it's not this look at all right all
right
constructing um constructing complex
entity classes no
setting up though
synthesizing what's the right term and
fundamentally it's these it's entity
function while defining well entry cost
implicitly / property values okay
and to answer that is true for these as
well and there is really I think that
the the implicitly define an city embryo
okay but then we need another
characterization entity classes defined
by computations
fair yes not no I don't think so
okay it could be all lookups
theoretically i suture said well
I mean what about computed entity
classes setting up computed entity
classes
I'm not sure okay let's let's see what
what it looks like when we start putting
things in here so Stephen the one thing
is you can view all these classes as
transformed entity classes from the
basements you know yeah I understand but
but um
about transformations and computations
on entity classes
okay let's see what we actually will put
in here okay so we would have entered a
function mmm I wouldn't put it in that
same group why because it's like all the
others are covariant this is
contravariant what do you mean what
would okay the description or entity
function is what the scripture entity
function is something that is like an
entity property but is computed so right
it's kind a multivariate entity poverty
what you can check various things
advance various properties also color do
you take into account the case maybe in
the future will entity function may
start returning something like an entity
class that doesn't change anything even
entity property here it's an ANSI glass
so you're saying more about the argument
of the entity function than the result
now the way I see it what really makes a
distinction is where it goes in entity
value yeah okay so entity function is
something that is for the second
argument when to the value at all the
ethicist therefore the first target okay
that's why you mentioned covariant and
contravariant and
so you view entity value as a kind of a
inner product no it's the Attic planet
really okay so hold on so in here we're
saying so entity function do we have
examples here oh gosh
right now if we don't have the usages
approved yet happened
so arguably we could put entity function
right underneath entity value is that a
fair statement fair thing to do
I would put it with any property readier
but it's not not gonna work on this page
right why not because too high up on the
page it's not that important it's a kind
of obscure thing relative to entity
value it's very mean in this page and
the value is the most important thing in
this page because it's the main resolver
everything well fair enough
maybe even entity list and as values
should be grouped separately as
resolvers in a separate group from the
others
you
you
okay so these things here could go
slightly lower down
you
do you agree with that Michael can you
comment on that yes I would
list entity class list where does that
go
doesn't even work
yes
it's one of the few functions and may be
the only one that acts on a type it is
in some sense a type property the list
of classics
I see so it doesn't belong here know of
a given generate of a given type it
doesn't generate them because there's an
explicit list somewhere of the named
entity classes
yes why is that keeping it
you
you
all right so you would claim maybe we
should put these up here
where does dated go does dated go in any
and any of these
it is related to properties we do we
mention anywhere here are we do
you
all right so then we've got entity
function
so how do we describe this we say
you
I
Factory is a dynamically computed
property symbolic representation of a
function of a dynamically computed of a
prop
dynamically computed from a function
no symbolic representation are they
function okay so the important part is
that
properties
you
with properties as variables is that
right no it's not true it's it's
generally empties its variables and then
you extracted them by using basically NC
value inside I see okay so that's in
fact the correct statement but in some
cases maybe entity classes as values
vilette's variables but like when these
cases when you're drunk when you're
aggregating no but it's not the classes
that are supplied as entities it small
transport transpose classes in a sense
no but that's their it classes if you
think about how entity value works yeah
how about that yeah
I mean I I'm not entirely happy about
this because it's like it's not really
that we have entry constructs as
variables it's more that parameters bind
to and she constructs but I guess I'm
being pedantic oh my let me say treating
except that breaks a line so we're not
allowed to do that okay hold on let's
look at yeah but I would say parameters
rather than variables close enough
you
okay sounds a bit Russian now uh okay we
should articulate it so to speak um okay
hold on this flow is not very good so
this is
I mean even entity until the properties
is also kind of a resolver
okay I think this is okay all right now
transfer me
applications on agita classes okay so
that's where it's basically this group
here is that correct yes
I have a feeling we should just list
those in a big line here unless we want
to pick out one of them as being a
useful one to mention okay what is the
only one that you think is particularly
strong and useful to mention
sorta
I like filter the next standard more
than sorted but what would we say for
filter identity class
entity class symbolic representation of
an entity class filtered by criterion
rather a predicate yeah
and it should be clear that the
predicate is entity function rather than
a usual function well they can look at
the documentation to find that out
do you support bear ante property as the
second argument yes okay
um
you
why shall we put we work heading could
be put here ah
you
utilities for the first three are kind
of uniform they give something like with
the semantics stripped that means
without the entity or entity property
wrapper yes
well dated maybe um yeah that's what I
was saying the first three are basically
extractors well so are these you say geo
position of something in that sense hmm
um
you
you
so you can play quantity to an entity
and get something some entities I think
yes sir for example
I think I don't know um Michael do you
want to comment on that I would guess
that a quantity is there because
entities return quantity oh I think so
too
in that case that whole line is well no
but sometimes geo position is you can
say geo position of an entity geo
position yes by the other tool no to my
knowledge data objects Aine thing if you
say if there's a battle or something I
think let's try it
you
we could make some work with quantity
say for physical constant entities but
we currently have them set it up
I had preferred okay actually for date
object it in general will be ambiguous
because entity may have more than one
date as a property but but the same for
clear position like whole country has
multiple geo positions yes
and the choice of averaging it for a new
position would be completely crazy for
Qantas all right let's not solve this
problem right here okay that so long as
what is this matching givenname pattern
did we we never did that right no
although we could that's in the category
not really I mean we could of course but
doing it efficiently might be
challenging
it's like find all species of snails
with names beginning with Q exactly I
mean yes we could make it work and we do
it partially on the website because
people use for course built puzzles but
I'm not sure if there's no critic for
the language yes in the relational world
we can do it pretty efficiently on that
hand well I think we should Road you
could do it efficiently if you ignore
linguistics yes
I mean if it's just canonical names it's
easy right Michael yeah but did the
creepy relativity point says because
yeah common names would be to get won't
one well it could we do it for common
names that will be easy as well wouldn't
it I mean it's only when we have to do
all linguistics that it gets hard yeah
but sometimes you have more than one now
do you have any one common name so let's
look at doing this find entities for
common names okay
it just seems useful um I mean
would work as you just say find entities
of Swing problem
yeah of type Commerce I'm almost doing
Padonia soon we are getting completely
sidetracked we haven't even started then
we have half hour left
okay all right okay thank you
okay let's keep going here
okay so then
should we just list every one of these
other ones just list them online on a
line here just to give people an idea of
what's going on and then we're going to
say dot dot dot and you know I have a
feeling we may need a separate guide
page specifically about these functions
that also mentions helper functions that
will go along with these what do you
think about that
what would the helper functions be I
don't know some of the functions that
you actually use inside merged and
aggregated and so on oh yeah inside yeah
Tony rather we don't
well yes you do because there's some
operations like arithmetic operations
that work
that will be probably a matter for
entity function because that on the page
of entity function we can say which
constructs can go inside and all these
operations they only use energy function
okay
you
you
should we
you
yeah okay all right let's go back over
here okay so the page that this was
referenced from is a page about
databases right
yes
okay
you
um
you
I'm not sure that this page I think this
page may need to be updated because
where where's the main page for entity
store where is the main guide page that
entity store is mentioned on Wow it
hardly gets mentioned
you
you
you
but that's irrelevant as well that talks
about that talks about only about SQL
databases so that needs to be fixed
okay sorry who is pianning here
under project
you
you
okay so this page needs to be updated
because
okay so this one is read right as it not
database linga street right yes
Stephen last time we decided to not
explicitly write it here because it's
obvious from the operations that are
listed below okay fair enough
relational database how could we
describe this as as you know relational
database inspection relational database
um
okay that goes to that page there
you could write I guess relational
database connection and metadata okay so
it's entities
um you know what I'm going to change the
way this is set up slightly complete
representation of custom entities and
their properties
okay so symbolic representation
okay so register an entity store so it's
entities can be used immediately or
something used transparently
what they're directly but do we need an
adverb there yes because you can always
use it ok so now here what I'm gonna do
I would say that you register an entity
stores so the entity value works with
those entities right well but that's I
think that's a reasonable way of saying
ok here because Indian we never
documented that you can use the
unregistered and historians on these
functions is that true you could use the
entity store but not kind of I should
say not the entities from the store in
some sense no yeah but you can you can
pass the NT store as a bracelet I always
failed to get my 12 point 12 plus that
Hey
yeah
I think this doesn't belong
you
you
hmm
you
you know I think the stuff should move
down on the page
and this were probably going to get rid
of her actually
we'll need a guide page about an Andrea
this is something we'll need a guide
page of all of our and to the property
stuff I think the entity property I
meant sorry but by that I mean all of
the domains that we're dealing with so
this here should be changed to be a
pointer to that guide page okay not
these functions which were largely
deprecating make sense select references
no I'm saying this should be a new guide
page which points to the new entity type
pages okay
also allows custom entity stores to be
added to behave is all a bit of a mess
of custom entity stores that behave hum
that allow computations just like in
whose entities what it's the entities
that behave not the stores
I'm not saying behave then that also
allows the addition of custom entity
stores that did add user-defined
entities to the knowledge base also
allows custom entity also supports
custom entity stores that allow
user-defined entities to be added to
allow and sister be added to user not
see we don't want to say to the nuts not
to the central knowledge basic or it so
support custom entities that allow
user-defined knowledge basis knowledge
base fragments because I think v2 BTUs
knowledge base in the single law is
meaning to all ok ok ok that allow
user-defined additions lots of back on
breathing um also support that behave
that allowed the same computations
as built-in knowledgebase
again I'm not sure this page is perfect
and I think we may need to refactor the
so yet again okay so this is called
database connectivity but database
student we have 20 minutes left we have
until kids 1 you stressed yet
well we're not gonna get through this
right now I mean I can already tell you
that but I told you this was going to
take a long time right we
got to go from this page to this page to
the messages okay so I'm gonna do us any
good to just jump in and look at one
random piece of text okay I mean we can
we can look at this but I don't think
it's gonna help very much no it's fine I
mean the only thing that it's like
really time that's really important that
we go through now is the entity class
thing because let's look at that so the
question is whether we should be able to
nest and see class just like the others
or not okay yeah go ahead so my claim is
that ante class is especially implicit
entity class can be a very nice
shorthand for when instead of writing
the full entity function when your field
is simple
well you haven't started leveraging
entity class yet I haven't touched it
because because Tony's of the opinion
that this shouldn't change at all okay
so what does BSU
so right now it's the class is
documented to take only a string type as
the first argument okay
and my claim means filtered entity class
can take anything as the first argument
so should entity class at the release
team implicit once because it's
basically a shorthand for the same thing
and so in cases where you basically just
have to say you know capital is wrong
then you don't want to type the fool
okay so if I were to say let me just try
something here if I were to say sample
the entity class of set a oops
why is that turning red I don't know if
it's in the builds in the building you
have yet so maybe say filtered entity
class or something there okay so let's
say filter the entity class set a and
now I'm going to say entity function and
you can see something like population
greater then I don't know some million
so here I'm gonna go to say C of
population greater than 10 to the seven
I wouldn't never read that because why C
because it will download all the city
so if you want to try it out right with
country
okay I assume it does an efficient job
of downloading those using the caching
infrastructure right yes okay so fine so
then I have this and now what do I want
to do I want to say entity list of this
right for example but you know they'll
all be course it needs to be a quantity
okay so can I just say that yes okay
okay so my claim is that by the way that
example should be given I mean that's a
decent example of
ah you know let me just put that on the
page about filter density class
to function actually
you
you
you
except let's change that to 10 to the 8
people
okay that's nice okay
so now we got along let's put this on
the page so while I'm thinking about it
let's put that on the page of entity
function
there's probably going property
relations frenzied function I think it's
a fairly minimal example of entity
function I mean is there a more minimal
one yeah you can just call entity value
with one entity one entity function but
why would you do that well to compute
something like I don't know the
population fancy
yeah but you could just compute
directly from the entity I mean you
could just compute it by extracting
those entities and dividing them yeah
but maybe yeah but it's I mean in the
future this is gonna be more efficient
it's certainly a lot more efficient on
stone SQL yeah right okay all right now
the question is whether I can take this
and make that an entity class is that
right yeah I suppose that now you want
to say area larger of some million
square miles so instead of I mean my
point is that this thing that you just
wrote could be expressed as an NC class
well this thing here I are somewhere
would how would I use that to the class
okay around it you you want to filter
another time for example okay okay let
me let me put it this way I could say
this I could say this without the entity
list right yes that without the entity
list and then I could say here I could
say area take largest four yeah so my
point is that in general they entered a
list of that yeah yes because entity
class can only appear with a string as
the first argument but my claim is that
increased entity class is in general
shorthand for filtering empty glass for
for shorter than three class and so why
should
differently no I would tend to agree
with that Tony yeah technically makes
sense but the only shows that the name
is missing the operation that it's doing
so it's name was intended to originally
for named entities and now it is used as
a wrapper to filter and that is not
obvious from the name but it's it's it's
used as a wrapper for filtering anyway
it's just it's just that it's a generic
wrapper and does different things
depending on the second argument well it
has this look entity class has the
shorthand way of doing filtering which
is less powerful and filtered entropy
class yeah but it saves a lot of
keystrokes right so I don't see a
problem with doing this you know I don't
see a problem with having that as an
alternative basically to filter an
entity class it's a minimal alternative
to filter data to us now the other
possibility would be to support entity
class like syntax in filtered entity
class is that crazy if we want to do
also take largest yes is then it's not a
filter anymore I see the same reason why
we can support the class and select it
is a fiddle it's just a non-local one
it's not a predicate yes
right okay well I think we should
support this I don't see a reason not to
support it we need a way to do it might
be basically to put forth one
well that's true also filter dancing
class well the other question is should
we support this also for name dancing
classes like first you take you filter
by population then you think just the
ones in g8 with that work I have no idea
you say comma g8 here I think this
should not very weird I think this is
not yeah it's very weird um okay so
question on the live stream about entity
extent yes that's now extended entity
class what to do with an unregistered
entity store what was the issue an
unregistered entity stores right if you
build it you have it not yet you are in
the portage of picking it up and once
you're already or you would eat it a
rigid on the file then you Vegas
right but registration is merely a
question of whether you can use it
directly you can use it indirectly but
by the way do we have I mean this that
you know we really need some tech notes
workflows etc to document all this stuff
because it's really not um you know this
is way too complicated to be able to
describe it and just in pure guide pages
and so on um okay so what we've got here
let's look at a random page here let's
say
sorted entity class
you
okay so listen we don't tend to use
these as adjectives or forms
you
that that's not a form we like to use to
use the function name as an adjective so
to speak okay um I think we just say an
entity class
I mean the point is all today it's not
necessarily an empty class object its
insuk us like object okay well then
don't say entity class like that
represents an entity class sorted by the
values of the property prop sorted
according to the values of the property
prop
you
how soon this cold will go away
represents an s-class
yeah well this has probably said better
but but okay I think that's fine
um okay it's a question about why not
automatically register an entity store
because um you have to resolve because
you can have multiple entities stores
that have the same entity type names in
them then you have to decide which one
is going to actually take over there has
to be a moment where you say this entity
type name is going to be the thing that
entities of that type with that first
argument are going to be resolved in
terms of that a fair statement goes
you
Tony I think that another argument is
that when would that happen at
evaluation time what do you feel like
manipulating the anti yeah but if you
have to add to these stores which have
the same type name Tony can you speak to
this please well they are being shadowed
one shadowing the other and that's not I
I know that I know that I know that but
in if you register one of them then it
will be the one that gets to grab that
type name yes whereas yeah so that's why
you have to you have to explicitly
register an Asda store and I wonder
whether we say that in register entity
store that we make that point
you
oops what is it entity store what is it
entity register
you
okay so that they can be used to
registers the entities in the entity
store so that they can be used directly
with entity yes so the analogy is that
you have a held expression settings I'm
going a notebook there's no way to
access that programmatically same if you
have an entity store unless you register
it you can't access its contents using
entity value what correct here I have to
say that I'm not really that happy about
and the register and the fact that we
haven't evaluated dollar and store I
mean I think that we should maybe anti
register is nice but we should keep
dollar and his store up to date with
entity register we have entity stores
open close yeah but the problem is that
no no what I'm saying is that whenever
we are writing tests and stuff like that
it's very useful to block dollar entry
store but dollar NT stores is not being
updated by entity register so it's nice
to Avenue and Tony can talk about this
okay
yes yes the sparkle stuff somebody's
asking Karl is asking on the live stream
rather the sparkle stuff will be
included in 12 oh yes absolutely in the
graph store um and in the in the craft
store think so so listen one thing that
I'm commenting on here is can you please
not as utilize things like entity store
YAG instead I can change that okay um
okay all right so let's go look here and
the time that remains let's go and look
okay
um
so let's call this what should we call
this data computation of the relational
databases rather than working with
something like um
they took us to make it clear that it's
a read-only operation but what are we
gonna just change the name of the guide
page when we support writing I would
think so okay but but well okay look
okay hold on here okay so here direct
data storage manipulation
data set
you
okay
so that's really the first case there
you
you
entity based okay that's fine
um then
this says
this is really relational database
operations but I don't think it's okay
okay
connection to an external SQL database
now somebody has suggested manipulating
relational database information it's
interesting although it suggests it a
little bit meta information
you
that makes it so more clear that it's
not
okay so here
we might want to mention enter the class
here
you
okay so here what should we say SQL
database object I'm not even sure we
have to mention on this page um database
inspect what is the discussion here
instead best inspect so there is expect
ok takes the disconnection returned
database SQL database object basically
you can say it retrieves the SQL
database metadata if you want something
more generic so why do two of those
functions not have two letters SQL in
their name and one has okay the reason
is that database connection is not very
specific to SQL in that it's more like
contains things like host port etc and
the other is inspect as well and in this
case I can imagine a database inspect
that takes MongoDB database connection
and return a MongoDB database object
okay wait a minute so their best suspect
is supported from MongoDB or not
no-nobody beeston has not made it into
system yet so no I understand so I think
I read this this has its own guide page
doesn't it Tony
yes three guide pages oh okay where does
it go where where's the top level one
that it should link to we need to put a
link in here yes so that's one for spark
a query and one for sparkle update also
I combined the combined one is what we
need to point to here okay so if you can
okay so could you somebody needs to put
that link in alright unless you want to
give it tell me the name of the page and
I'll put the link in graph store
overview but it's not in CS well it
needs to be there and that needs to be
linked to it okay all right so
here we're going to list I see maybe we
don't want to make and we don't want
that there
okay so what is the description here um
extract
metadata from a database or specific
tables is that right
I wouldn't mention tables in the in case
we extend these two days they don't have
tables well this is in the section on
relational databases so it can talk
about tables okay it seems like a weird
name for what this is doing what would
you call it but what is it what is it
returning I mean it's its return it what
does it return returns SQL database
object as opposed to database connection
it takes some dummies connection okay
then then hey base object how do you
then refer to okay tell me how you how
you okay the thing is that SQL database
object can out-cook is actually already
it's from constructure constructor so in
theory you could get rid of this
function and use SQL database object as
the constructor directly okay but how do
you connect that to an entity or an
entity class you need to then wrap it in
and his store and then register there
and see store okay so I scaled it up his
objects he's a lower level description
okay so we're gonna have to put this
stuff up at the top here and we'll have
to say um okay
connecting to database to a database to
databases
um registering database content or
something right and then that has to go
into then there has to be an entity
register there right
animal want
you
you
something like that is that correct is
that correct or not
I think so yeah okay so we're gonna have
to wrap right now we will have to come
okay just one little thing I mean maybe
we're gonna speak about it next time but
I guess this is the last call to do to
do this the SQL database job objects
that really were still acting I'm SQL at
the beginning think it's redundant the
reason why we added I think is because
we wanted to distinguish between no
sequel and stuff but I guess you know if
in the future we're gonna have like no
zero support we can have no sequel
database object and that this one can't
just start up a table because India
databases please to me I relational is
true there also no sequel databases but
we can have I don't my countless work
for any database see : obstacle doesn't
make any difference it's just it's just
got all kinds of detailed information it
just represents the database different
properties so yes the other problem is
also that we are using SQL database
object to dispatch different data
sources to different backends and that
can only who cares then you can look
inside the thing I owe my point is that
it's best to have this guy debate object
and there's no that's not gonna work
okay you shouldn't have brought this up
right off to the end of the hour meeting
time okay yeah yeah sure I think this
should be called database object and I
think you should plan to have it be able
to look inside you know that's not how
up values work sooner beauty and
latching on all these functions on this
but that's not how you're gonna do it no
no what I'm saying is that entity store
this patch is on that symbol nobody can
look inside it just has to have more
code to look inside it's not difficult
to look inside don't don't give me that
that's a silly implementation problem I
think this should be called database
object I agree
the
okay I think we should rename this
database object and expect to look
inside it to see what what will actually
be done with it
all right I need to go um I will push
these these changes and we will follow
this up very soon okay I I think this is
gonna take another on the order of four
hours total to get this documentation
done okay but I encourage you to fix
that d.a tricked eye realization and I
encourage you get get a default um
database that you know get these SQLite
databases installed and start making
examples make sense sure okay
see you guys thanks to folks on the
livestream and talk to y'all soon